Good morning, John.
I have a kind of remarkable skill that I've
never talked about here on Vlogbrothers.
Spent a lifetime time of work to master it,
it requires a truly mesmerizing amount of
muscle control in my mouth and throat and
abdomen.
It can be beautiful, it can be terrifying,
depending on my mood, and only one out of
every 8.7 million species on earth can do
it.
Possibly the most remarkable thing I am capable
of doing, I am doing right now.
Talking.
WORDS!
Noises come out of my mouth!
And I direct them at people.
And then the people are like "Yeah I'll meet
you at Buffalo Wild Wings at 7."
It's a miracle.
And it's kind of a miracle we don't notice
how remarkable this ability is.
And we have words for everything!
Like, just look around.
This is a book, it's called a book.
But there's more words here.
This is paper and this is cardstock.
This is embossed, it's a embossed cover.
This is a spine, there's blurbs on it.
Blurb!
Blurb is a word!
This is a llama head stitched to the body
of an elephant theres a word for that.
This thing, put it around your neck, theres
a word for it.
Lanyard!
What--who--came--what--why?
We have words for words.
Nouns and verbs and adjectives and adverbs.
And words for words that mean the same things
as other words.
And words for things that are the opposite
meanings of other words.
We have so many words that there are some
words that mean the opposite of themselves!
Inflammable means both very easy to catch
on fire and very hard to catch on fire.
Sanguine means both cheerful and bloodthirsty.
Good news though, we have a word for when
words mean the opposite of the thing that
they mean.
But if we didn't have a word for it, there
would still be a word for it because we have
a word for when there isn’t a word for a
thing.
Yeah, take so time to think about that.
It is so unusual to encounter a situation
in which you don't have a word for a thing
that most people don't even know there is
a word for when the thing doesn't have a word
for it.
We have a word for the best possible word
to use in any given situation which means
that if you need the best possible word to
describe the best possible word, it describes
itself.
In fact there are a number of words that describe
themselves.
A noun is a noun.
'Cutsey' sounds kind of adorable.
'Magniloquent' means grandiose and also sounds
grandiose.
'Polysyllabic' is polysyllabic, 'unhyphenated'
is unhyphenated, and at one point the word
'coined' was coined.
You will not, probably, be surprised to find
that there is a word for words that describe
themselves.
And that word is autological and it is also
autological in that it describes itself.
Blbhblbhh!
That's not the hard part though.
The hard part is that autological has an antonym
which is heterological, and heterological
doesn't describe itself because it doesn't
describe itself.
But it does describe itself because--so it's
autologic but if it's not autologic, it's
not autological because it's heterological
so if it's hetero--but if it is heterological
then it is autological.
[groans, burps]
Luckily, we got a word for that too.
Last year, John and I conducted a census of
nerdfighteria because we wanted to know more
about this community, and we wanted this community
to know more about itself.
Also it helps us decide what to focus our
time on, where we might go on tour, what new
shows to be thinking about doing.
The general goal of the census is to make
nerdfighteria a better place.
So if you have time--and it does take some
time, like 10 to 30 minutes, it's not an insignificant
little survey; there are some real questions
on it that we really want you to answer--then
check the link in the description and fill
out the census.
We will be very thankful.
And it will be making this community better!
Also in the doobly-doo there's a link to nerdfighteria.com,
where you can sign up for a weekly newsletter,
which you should do because it will keep you
informed on all sorts of amazing things going
on in the world.
And a list of nerdfighter events that are
happening all over the world that YOU can
participate in.
Thank you all for being a part of this community
and for putting up with me being confused
about words.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
Grand, mad, madniloquent.
Grandiloquent.
Grandilo--grah, ahhh!
Possible word then did jus jut ahhh cckah
hahahaa--this!
Is, oh!
And that word is autogihblahhohah.